how much did marketing factor into your
decision to shoot on the iphone actually
it didn't factor into it whatsoever I
mean we couldn't even get we got I think
we reached out to iPhone at one point to
see if they would even lend us or give
us iphones to shoot and perhaps what
ever department we reached out to didn't
they declined I think it was probably
because of the subject matter being the
fact that it was focusing on sex work so
we knew that perhaps the the film would
get attention because of it or to a
certain degree but it wasn't in any way
calculated or planned it wasn't
something for example the most we really
wanted to actually keep it out of the
news until we premiered at sundance we
didn't want people going into Sundance
thinking I'm going to go see this iphone
movie nobody knew actually until the
very end of the film when the final
credits it says showed me iphone 5s and
that was the first time anybody outside
our small circle knew that this film was
shot on that so then when you do the QA
yeah afterward right we're most of the
questions directed toward no fifty-fifty
yeah right now what seems to happen in
these Q&A is is that fifty percent of it
is about the tech and then fifty percent
of a of it is about the trans movement
and how we approached that sensitive
subject matter and being from outside
that world how we decided to to actually
form a story work with our with our
actors and and and make this film
you